i'm convinced
and you tell me if you agree with us or
not kai you too david youtube i'm
convinced we
are born conservative or liberal
i'm convinced you're born
left or right
i'm convinced you're born with left
tendencies or right tendencies
i believe the majority of the population
is born on those two sides let me
explain i'll give you my argument and
please trash the argument and folks i
want you to trash this argument as well
as we're going through tell me if you
agree with us or not
so for example i had a friend of mine
who married a girl who was a full-on
socialist we go to dinner together and
i'm listening to her
i couldn't understand like she was
out of this world completely like aoc is
the greatest all this stuff rich people
are this capitalism sucks all they care
about is money non-stop she's going
and i pause this can i ask you a
question she said yeah i said what was
your favorite subject in high school she
said uh art
i said what else
journalism what else
music
how do you feel about math oh i hate
math
really why do you hate math i just i've
never liked math it always came hard to
me and from the moment i started taking
that it made me feel like i'm dumb it
made me feel like i'm not smart i've
just never liked math
got it
for the last 10 years i've been asking
people this question who's on the left
who's on the right how they are with
math it's not always right but about
seventy percent of time eighty percent
of the time
it's right you'll notice most people
that our right brain will lean left a
lot of people that are left brain
will lean right right but then there is
a small populace okay which is
like you know in america today there's a
percentage of americans you cannot make
them vote right there's nothing you can
do about it it's about 44 right
you can say whatever you want to say
they're not going to vote republican
okay
there's 42 percent that no matter what
you say to them they're not going to
vote democrat that's just kind of what
you're dealing with then you've got a
little bit of the the whole thing we
talked about with uh what do you call it
libertarian libertarian independence
give those four five you're really
dealing with what 10 or 12 percent right
i think 12
of america
kids are born not just america kids are
born 12 percent of kids are born and
those are the ones that are kind of like
huh i kind of see what you're saying
that's a good point let me see what he
has to say you know what gerard you made
a good point phil you know i don't know
i agree with him now but gerard he just
said something huh let me kind of weigh
this out they're malleable i think
there's about 12 that's malleable okay
if you are able to whoever converts that
12 percent the best that party wins so
this isn't about fighting somebody
that's never going to swa a switch
left or right this is about finding that
12 percent of reasonable people that are
willing to sit there and say here's my
argument what do you think well pal what
do you think i read one time in the
article said this well here's what i
think about this why i disagree with you
cool let's go back and forth banter i'm
convinced people are born left and
people are born right and the goal is to
find that 12 percent that's malleable
that you can shift their thinking and
let them have that debate to make a
decision for themselves what are your
thoughts how many of those 40
on either side
believe they're in that 12 percent from
hearing this
how many
how many the 40 how many of the 40
percent unswayable on either side oh
they know listening to this no they
don't no no they know vince they're in
that dream let me put it to you this way
the group that knows they're not is a
group that says pat has no clue what the
hell he's talking about but there's a
group that's listening to this that's
saying
i can't say this to anybody i can't
admit to it definitely i cannot admit to
anybody but i got to tell you lately
i've been kind of questioning some of
this it's like not making any sense
why the hell would you get rid of you
know ap and honors program okay tell me
how that makes any sense why the hell
would you fire this person why the hell
would you want to do this to taxes and
change the incentives why the hell would
you want to give people money to
non-stop i saw how my dad did that to my
sister my sisters now this yeah i don't
know if i'm stuff is starting to make
sense to me like believe me the 12
of the populace is already questioning
it on both sides they're sitting there
questioning it on both sides challenges
to be able to convert them so if this is
true let's just say if this is true yeah
if this is true you know what this means
88 of arguments are worthless
[Laughter]
i do believe that
88 percent of the debates are awarded
did you understand what i said
if this is correct so protect your
energy big time yeah 88 is a waste of
time are you saying this is exclusive in
america or no no worldwide no i think
this is this is worldwide and you're
saying born
i think you're born like how you say
you're born gay you're born straight
there's nothing no you know what it is
nature versus nurture you're saying this
is something greatly i'm not saying i'm
giving
you're born politically laughter
politically right yes
i
i'm not buying it yeah i mean listen i
knew you weren't gonna buy it i know
well i'll tell you why i knew you
weren't gonna buy it like recently i had
a conversation that's what i was asking
united states worldwide like so for
instance my sister yeah loves trump okay
loves trump
same
fair parent same dad same mom loves
trump she couldn't tell you one point
she's gonna lose her job for love and
trump or she's gonna be okay this
hasn't worked in years she's married to
a
wealthy dentist damn yeah i said it
um
bro
she's uh
yeah
sounds like adam he's just making sure
she's all right she what's funny
she's is
a communist dictator damn um that just
her husband is a wealthy dentist awesome
anyway we're on fire today
i promise you he loves you i promise you
love you keep going
i do love my sister do i like her we'll
see
um
but she loves talking don't you talk
about it yeah let's let's bring it up
let's go a 10-minute dive trap my family
bring a couch here let this guy lay down
for a quick session that's right that's
gerard
um
so another conversation i had recently
was with a friend of mine from israel
yeah and they were obviously you see a
lot of results that are happening with
the vaccine not to get too vaccinated
right now
but i said who's hesitant in israel
taking the vaccine
and they go oh no it's uh it's uh
it's the people on the left
i said what
they go yeah yeah the people on the way
left they don't they don't they don't
want to do anything with the vaccine i
said hold on let me get this straight
because traditionally in the united
states it's
not traditionally like we've seen
a lot of young male
skewing right
do not want to take the vaccine a lot of
african-americans will take it as well
sure right and then so they flipped it
on me they were like yeah you know it's
the people on the left highly educated
um
just
factors that you did not expect to hear
highly educated people here too actually
questionably no no it's um quantifiably
we did it three podcasts so phds the um
so it wasn't a left
red button like it flipped it so the
point is this
i'm not i'm not understanding like
depending on where you're born
depending on what country you're in
i think politics is completely different
i don't think just because you were born
in the united states that you're
automatically going to be on the left or
the right so let me let me let me
understand why so here's the question
let me go a little bit later deeper okay
you ever seen a family same mom and dad
four kids
one becomes a phenom crushes it
one just a regular government employee
one becomes a drug addict and one
becomes a priest you ever notice like
what the hell just happened same mom and
dad same environment same upbringing
four different human beings yeah yeah
yeah i think there's a part of your dna
where you're wired in a certain way and
a big part of it is politically because
because so don't get me wrong i have
these other four issues that i add to it
i made a video about this four years ago
i think it has to do with your
upbringing and i think it has to do with
your family i think it has to with your
a first person that took a liking into
you and gave you a lot of love and you
feel like there's a certain level of
loyalty to that person whether that
person is a left or right or rich or
poor or whatever it is you kind of have
that loyalty to that person a person
early on that was an influencer that you
started reading up on you're like oh my
gosh i believe in this guy's philosophy
i think all that stuff has also placed
it and then i think it also has to do
with if you had a bad experience with
gun when you were you know 16 years old
one of your little nephews or you know
nieces saw a gun that left it their shot
themselves you're probably never going
to like this is all stuff that happens
while growing up though sure
i agree i agree but i still think
there's a part of people where your
wiring is to be once said because there
is no way a guy on the left and a guy on
the right
smart both on both sides they're smart
on both sides you know left things the
rights dummies and the right things the
people on the left are down neither one
of them are dumb then what is it with
them because they're both very convicted
in their beliefs how did that happen
it's what they prioritize so
you know the
i i tend to agree with you but i also
tend to agree with adam i don't think
it's a left and right issue because
politics are constantly evolving i do
think that there's a proclivity to
either value intellect or emotion i
think that some people don't care
whether or not you're right as long as
you make somebody feel good you
understand like there's some people that
are like i don't care if i'm right as
long as that person feels good and
comfortable with me and then there's
other people that are like if that
person can't be comfortable with the
truth to hell with them right and that's
that's
that's definitely me right yeah you can
ask the the
truth that was just written about peter
thiel contrarian right that you keep
talking about you know maybe maybe it's
conform and non-conform
maybe it's it's agree and disagree maybe
it's
question and don't question maybe it's
that but to me there isn't element of
some people that just say oh yeah yeah
some people have to be like yeah they
have to yeah some people are just kind
of like but you know there's a part of
that again look at the creative side
though
creative is typically
hollywood is creative left you look at
how the creative typically leans left
you look at the logic typically leans
right you know what you say about the
country singers there are a lot of them
that are right and they're all creative
good point
country singers that are what that are
on the right yeah then that goes to how
they're raised and that goes to their
upbringing that goes to you know their
rituals and their values for the country
and what they saw that goes to that part
as well but that's a very small genre of
the the industry remember i'm not saying
this is a hundred percent i'm saying
percent there's a there's a thirty
percent output to your point i feel like
politics is almost like religion i was
born into a jewish family you know we
were doing jewish practices customs and
traditions if i happen to be uh you know
my dad is a percentage italian and for
whatever reason he married an italian
woman i would have born into a catholic
family and i would have been a catholic
and i agree like
religion more than anything it's around
you know what you're raised around and
that's what you're going to be if i
wasn't sure but think about it
validates my point this more validates
my point what percentage am i talking
about ten percent right
ninety percent of people if your dad's a
christian you're a christian if your mom
is a catholic you're a catholic but
there's a 10 that's kind of like i have
to figure this out for myself you think
it's only 10 that seems so that seems so
low i don't i think it's that small of a
percentage
i think it's that small of a percentage
the predator theory is 80 20 whether
it's 10 or 20 it's not a big number i'm
telling you right now it is not a big
number mo go back to your classroom and
think about who was like okay yeah okay
yeah okay yeah and i think about some of
the guys are like well how about this
how about if we try this come over this
what about that why do we do this why
did this take place what about that what
about this
there is the white person i want to know
more tell me give me some depth in this
right so that it's not a big deal how do
you have massive cultural changes like
how does how does uh slavery end if
that's the case how do how do things
evolve how does it end yeah because
somebody questioned it so one of that
ten percent
one of that ten percent comes out of
course and then the they they are able
to convert what we'll go back and go
back more
go back to our meaning go back to
genocides go back to any of these events
that took place man like when you're in
it you don't even know when you're in it
you're thinking there is no out
but there is a 10
small percentage that has faith that
this can change and they're willing to
stand up
slavery stopped because of who does that
percent what happened
let me ask you a question let me ask you
a question let me ask you a question let
me ask you a question this is not no
conspiracy theory it's just a question
i'm about to ask you okay so don't flip
out here folks who are you know this is
just the question
the cause of lincoln's death
the doctor
abraham lincoln
the cause of lincoln's dead you know at
the fore theater everyone's been there
you've seen okay
what was it cause is it just a black and
white cause
no it's a series of events
okay the the the
the security guard leaving his post you
know john wilkes booth obviously the
conspiracy shooting and then a lot of
people think that lincoln could have
somehow survived the doctor might have
actually accelerated his death too so
well
okay fine let go put a percentage on it
you think people like the fact that he
stood up as a republican against those
who liked slavery no literally half the
nation left okay so that's the point
there look at this guy who's a president
who could have easily said yeah let's
just go one more i'm not going to be the
guy let grant be the one that fights for
something like this this guy stood up
for it how many people would have done
that not a lot of people most people
pass the buck right that's a 10
community the 10 community is not
believe it or not it's the 10 percent
that has the courage to stand up and
talk about stuff that others don't want
to talk but what happened last night
when we're talking to this guy i want to
say his name because that's his business
what did he say i just you know i
living in california you saw where he
was living in california and you know we
were talking
politics
you know biden's you know flips out luke
all of a sudden he went from zero to
pissed off he was like this the entire
time yep composure the next thing you
know boom right and we're like and you
live in california yeah
dude what the hell just happened right
now that's costing his business flips
out cost him his business of course it
cost me his business but guess what he
says yeah i don't want to do the social
media stuff because they come after you
that's ninety percent yep that's ninety
percent because who the hell wants that
he's gonna have to pass the buck i'ma
pass the buck you try to do no no i'm
gonna pass the buck now i'm gonna pass
the ball you don't want the pressure i
think
the 10
of people who have the audacity to
question are the ones that are going to
say man this goes all the way back to
our initial conversation about the kids
you start reducing that percentage
you get
the least amount of leaders that
actually want to speak up and speak out
and do
there's by the way there's nothing like
like look right now i'm the host of this
show i'm presenting this you guys are
disagreeing i'm not offended this is how
it's supposed to be this is how we're
learning this is how we go back and
forth and i'm finding leaks in my
argument and saying well like i got a
bunch of papers sitting on my desk to go
look at this is how this course takes
place right where you get better this is
how it is with the kids as well this is
a conversation but i think the 10
percenters
are gonna like us i don't think the 90
of the audience likes us to be honest
with you i think i think if you're part
of 90 community i guys said this the
other day on twitter uh he tweeted this
i don't know if you guys saw this or not
he said something to me the other day
and i retweeted and i responded to him
he said you know i don't know what to
make of you pat oh
did you see that says i don't know what
to make of you i saw that he says uh
uh he says uh you know one minute you're
this and one minute your dad i don't
even know if i have it maybe i okay
there it is he says patrick i really
don't know what to do with you i just
can't categorize you which is
frustrating you're like a moving target
that is very difficult to hit one moment
you're fantastic the next moment you're
very disappointed i'm at my wits
with you right and i respond i said
there will be more changes coming soon
so save yourself to frustration and
agony and move on yeah it doesn't sound
healthy for you i wish you nothing but
the very best you know why you know why
because we're questioning yeah and we're
like trying to get a little bit more to
say well you know i don't know you know
just put it together to define you they
want to box you in they want to say oh
no this is him and this is what oh hold
on what what
that doesn't add up adam it's more blows
their mind it's more than that they they
don't they don't want to hear what you
have to say they want to hear you saying
what they want oh yeah exactly right
they want to speak to an echo champion
you actually made a great point before
about the intersection between politics
and religion that is
where we're at right now so when you
can't have an intellectual conversation
with something that's so emotional right
normally it would be or or the way it
was supposed to be politics were
intellectual right it's a discussion
about how to allocate resources in
government right there there's always a
sliding scale there's sometimes we need
more there's sometimes we need less and
it should always be over discussion
right religion is is for people it's
eternal it's the eternal truth this is i
am right everybody else is wrong and i'm
betting my eternal soul on it right so
there is there there's this idea of of
when you question someone's religion
you're questioning their entire identity
you're not questioning their
decision-making in the moment you're
questioning who they are as a person so
as people have taken their politics and
they've taken their political
perspective as their religion as their
worldview and as their personality you
can't disagree with them politically
because now you're disagreeing with the
essence of their themselves you're
saying you're a bad person you don't
understand and that's that's a really
really dangerous place to be so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]